wir haben ja heute eine unschöne Meldung
so ich wollte gerade darauf kommen
ja der Marktführer im Bereich ist es
ironisch ausgerechnet der Marktführer im
Bereich Wärmepumpen ja und um es noch
mal ein bisschen ironischer zu machen
der deutsche Marktführer im Bereich
werbepumpen Komma das Land das wie kann
anderes in Wärmepumpen in Zukunft was
passiert ist eine hoch angesehene Marke
die werden jetzt an die USA verkauft das
halte ich noch nicht an und für sich das
Problem oder so viele Unternehmen und
Branchen die auch an irgendwie USA oder
so verkauft werden aber für mich konnten
es ist so ein bisschen ein Dejavue
nämlich von vor 10 15 Jahren was mit der
Solar Technologie passiert ist wo damals
nicht zuletzt unter auch enormer
staatsanstrengung die Solartechnologie
Deutschland mal führend war und dann
wanderte das ab
in Richtung Asien und man hat das die
chinesisches billiger gemacht und so
weiter und dann waren es damals
tatsächlich schon hat man dann auch
gesagt gesagt okay wir wollen da ja auch
nicht in die Märkte zu sehr eingreifen
wenn die das billiger machen können dann
sollen sie es machen nur jetzt merken
wir dass wir zu 86 Prozent unserer
photovoltaikanlagen sind kommen aus
China und inzwischen sind die
Solarunternehmen in China da auch so
selbstbewusst und sagen da naja wenn ihr
klar kommt unsere Solarpanelen aus
dieser Region King Jang wo nachweislich
Zwangsarbeit ist und dann haben wir das
Lieferketten gesetzt und dann ähm
komm komm komm die Deutschen mit
Menschen rechnen und sagen die sich
chinesischen Unternehmer knallhart was
wollt ihr wollt ihr die Energiewende
oder wollt ihr die Menschenrechte wenn
ihr die wenn ja wegen der Menschenrechte
und auf unsere solarpanieren verzichten
wollen wir finden genug Abnehmer was ist
damit sagen will wir haben uns in so
einer Abhängigkeit gegeben und das
wiederholt sich anscheinend jetzt mit
der Wärmepumpe weil das Problem ist
nicht dass man jetzt
US-Investoren sondern das billig billig
quasi im Voraus einem Gehorsam der Markt
den Asiaten lassen werden und das halte
ich für ein Problem und ich glaube das
wäre Aufgabe jetzt für die Politik da
ich auch zu gucken wenn wir das als ein
Bereich einen wichtigen Bereich sehen
durchaus auch als Teil einer
Schlüsseltechnologie da muss der Staat
da die Politik da auch gezielt das
Fördern und diese Technologien nicht so
gehen und jetzt jetzt gerade wirklich
interessant Frau Weber weil heute eine
topökonomen hier sitzt und noch gespannt
was Kerstin Münstermann dazu sagt also
die politische Antwort darauf und dann
siehst Du danke danke
Ironie und jeder spaß beiseite
das ist ja wirklich üblich ist Dejavue
so wie Sie es gerade beschreiben und der
Grund scheint ja offenbar zu sein der
Grund für diesen Verkauf für diesen
Entschluss immer muss man sich klar
machen Angela Merkel hat die besucht das
dann sehr
innovatives gutes mittelständisches
Unternehmen Champion nicht so viele gibt
in Deutschland und die haben immer
gesagt wir sind in der Lage diese
Wärmepumpen zu bauen da wird es keine
Probleme geben wir können das wir sind
innovativ genug man hat darüber
nachgedacht in Osteuropa zugegeben aber
immerhin dort neue Werke aufzubauen und
zu sagen okay dann fertigen wir das eben
dort weil in Deutschland die Dinge zu
teuer sind wie auch immer und jetzt gibt
es offenbar die große Sorge
nicht vor den Amerikanern wie herrlich
gerade zurecht sagt sondern die große
Sorge wir werden demnächst überschwemmt
werden mit günstigeren mit billigeren
Wärmepumpen aus Südostasien und wir
werden nie und nimmer in der Lage sein
zu konkurrenzfähigen Preisen weiter zu
produzieren und anzubieten das heißt wir
haben hier auf kurz oder lang ein echtes
Problem
wie reagiert man auf so eine Situation
und die Parallele zur Photovoltaik ist
ja frappierend also wir entwickeln das
wir bringen es zum Marktreife wir finden
Kunden dafür wir finden dafür und am
Ende machen andere das riesen business
also ich glaube so eine allgemeinere
Logik die sich auch durch diese Debatte
zieht ist dass der Fokus in Deutschland
immer darauf liegt was man eigentlich
alles abschalten möchte und beenden
möchte und sehr viel weniger darauf was
man eigentlich aufbauen möchte und was
man eigentlich neu ist in die Welt
springen möchte und dann gibt es eben
diese Anfänge wie bei den werbepumpen
und wie bei der bei der
solarindustriekraft sagen
die die Schnellzüge sagen und so weiter
also gibt es viele Technologien wo das
genauso läuft und dann wird aber eben
nicht ambitioniert genug investiert um
diese neuen Technologien wirklich in der
Breite in Deutschland umzusetzen und in
der Breite sozusagen zu einer
reindustrialisierung beizutragen und ich
glaube da gibt es eben so ein so ein
anfängliche
politische Unterstützung und auch eine
Anerkennung dass in dieser Anfangsphase
staatliche Einmischung irgendwie
nützlich sein kann und dann danach denkt
man dass man sich dann eben komplett auf
den freien Markt verlassen kann ohne
sozusagen die Hausaufgaben fertig
gemacht zu haben und sichergestellt zu
haben das wirklich diese Industrien ähm
dann sich auch so entwickelt haben dass
sie auf der Massenbasis funktionieren
können
wenn wir nicht in der Lage sind das
Kapital das Geld die Energie was auch
immer auch die die gesetzlichen
Rahmenbedingungen so zu gestalten dass
wir in der Lage sind das Ding einfach
mal von A bis zu Ende zu entwickeln
es ist schon überraschend und man fragt
sich wo das herkommt und man fragt sich
auch wie die ganzen anstehenden Themen
von grüner Transformation von
wasserstoffinfrastruktur und so weiter
eigentlich gelingen sollen wenn man mit
dieser Haltung rangeht ich bin ja ganz
bei Ihnen das ist schön wäre eine
ausgiebige
wasserstoffinfrastruktur zu haben aber
ich glaube dann braucht man eben auch
einen Plan und ich weiß Plan das ist
kein besonders beliebtes Wort aber
trotzdem glaube ich tatsächlich dass man
einen Plan braucht der eine klare
Strategie involviert und eben dann auch
eine solche Infrastruktur aufbaut und
gerade Infrastrukturen entstehen in der
Regel nicht einfach nur durch die
unsichtbare Hand des Marktes sondern
brauchen auch klare politische
commitments um dann diese Infrastruktur
auch eben von A bis Z umzusetzen und
nicht löchrecht wie ein Schweizer Käse
und zögerlich die asiatischen
Volkswirtschaften
die Solartechnologie
ein komplett nach China abgewandert ist
das hat natürlich damit zu tun dass der
Staat darin gesehen hat gar nicht mal so
sehr um dem Westen jetzt eins
auszuwischen oder den Deutschen sondern
haben sie haben auf dem Land gesehen
okay die Leute haben ja noch nicht mal
Strom und warmes Wasser und wir sorgen
dafür dass die chinesischen Unternehmen
Solarpanelen Omas in einer hohen Zahl
produzieren können was sie
Produktionskosten dann senkt so dass ich
quasi jeder Bauer quasi so eine
Solarpaneele dann hinstellen kann und
warmes Wasser und das war so quasi der
Grundgedanke dass damit einher quasi die
zum Weltmarktführer geworden ist das
natürlich dann einen willkommen danebene
Effekt gewesen aber um nun nur mal zu
erklären sowas also all diese Dinge und
dann würde ich ihn komplett zustimmen
also sowas passiert halt leider nicht
über die freien Marktkräfte und ich
glaube da haben wir uns zu lange zu sehr
darauf verlassen dass das irgendwie
schon klappen wird und verkennen dabei
das andere Staaten andere Region mit
ganz anderen Spielregeln spielen
können wir blöd finden aber wir müssen
uns damit auseinandersetzen und müssen
auf eine Art auch reagieren und ich sehe
das in viel immer mehr Bereichen und die
Solartechnologie das hätte uns ein
warnendes Beispiel sein können aber
zum nächsten Thema kommt zu
Elektromobilität und so weiter das ist
ja ein also soll dass ich jetzt diesen
Begriff aus der Atomtechnologie nehme
aber was wir gerade bei der Automesse in
Shanghai erlebt haben das ist für die
deutschen Autobahn eine also ähm wir
haben es alle unterschätzt wir haben als
Journalist da haben wir schon immer
kritisch auch auf die deutschen
Autobauer geschaut als 2017 die
chinesische Regierung eine Quote
festgelegt hat das 10% aller Autos
künftig die in China verkauft werden
Elektroautos sein müssen da war zu
fangen die auch deutschen Autobahn
natürlich nicht besonders toll haben da
auch Druck gemacht dann waren die weil
die chinesische Führung durchaus kulant
jetzt ist quasi von selbst also diese
Quote gerissen worden jetzt wird jedes
vierte Auto wir reden von 25% aller
Autos die jetzt verkauft werden sind
Elektroautos und plötzlich spielen die
deutschen Autobauer die jahrzehntelang
auf den vordersten Plätzen und VW war
immer Marktführer vor kurzem
spielen die in diesen
elektromobilitätsbereich nur noch eine
marginale Rolle 2,5%
Marktanteil VW bei E-Autos in China
mit dem Verbrennermotor irgendwie noch
gut verkaufen das wollen wir ausreizen
und so weiter und dann diese Diskussion
hier um e-fuels und irgendwas also das
geht all diesen
dünnes Eis essen
Entwicklung vorbei der Automarkt wird in
China entschieden weil dort die größten
Wachstums äh äh Chance noch bestehen ähm
weil China schon längst der größte
Automarkt ist weil China inzwischen auch
der Technologieführer in diesen
Mobilitätsbereich sind und plötzlich auf
einen Schlag sind die Deutschen so in
der Defensive ich mache mir ganz ganz
große Sorgen und in der Geschwindigkeit
wie das vonstatten geht das ist das
schockieren und dann höre ich dann
teilweise die Debatten die hier geführt
werden und da denke ich mir Leute also
hier kleinen kleinen wir verheddern uns
hier total während die Uhr ganz schon
viel weiter tickt also das macht mir
wirklich große Sorgen und ich habe das
Gefühl irgendwie das dass das hier
überhaupt noch nicht angekommen Frau und
wir reden gleich über wenn es notwendig
ist auch das äh ich ich wollte ich
wollte Sie fragen um dann noch mal eine
Zahl draufzulegen und dann wird einem
klar dass sozusagen das wie soll man
sagen der der gute Wille unabhängiger zu
werden den kann man ja haben und den
sollte man vielleicht auch haben und man
darf die Chinesen auch kritisieren das
tun die ihrerseits übrigens auch und
reden auch sehr hart und klar ist alles
okay aber die Wahrheit ist doch wenn man
sich anschaut wie sich der
Automobilmarkt entwickelt dass wir das
uns schlicht untergreifend nicht mehr
leisten können China wird in einem
Jahrzehnt einen Automobilmarkt haben der
wird so groß sein wie der gesamte
amerikanische und gesamte europäische
Automarke zusammen so groß
das heißt wenn wir dort nicht mitspielen
haben wir ein Thema ja auf jeden Fall
und da muss man sich glaube ich auch
immer vor Augen führen dass die USA
natürlich ein Land ist das ein
importüberschuss hat und Deutschland
eigentlich immer den Anspruch hatte
Exportweltmeister zu sein und insofern
in dieser ganzen Auseinandersetzung mit
China Deutschland in einer strukturell
komplett anderen Situation ist als die
USA ich wollte noch mal das anknüpfen
was Herr li gesagt hat und ich glaube es
ist ganz wichtig hier anzuerkennen dass
bei beiden Beispielen sowohl der
E-Mobilität als auch den Solarzellen
Photovoltaik jetzt die Wärmepumpen also
ich sage mal schön ist das alles nicht
das ist bei all diesen Nenner es geht
auch nicht einfach nur im staatismus in
China sondern es geht darum dass der
Staat auf eine sehr geschickte Art und
Weise sichere Märkte Chef schafft und
den Unternehmen sagt hier sind Garantie
garantierte Märkte für diese Bereiche
geht macht produziert und es gibt eine
brutale Konkurrenz in diesen Bereichen
wenn man in Peking heute mit dem Taxi
unterwegs ist sieht man alle möglichen
Automarken die man noch nie gehört hat
die auch die Chinesen teilweise nicht
kennen weil so viele neue Unternehmen
ganz vorwiegend private Unternehmen
entstehen die auf diese auf diesen
garantierten Markt des Staates reagieren
insofern glaube ich dass wir in diesen
Zeiten von Zeitenwende in diesen Zeiten
von enormen Herausforderungen auch neu
darüber nachdenken müssen wie eigentlich
Staat und Markt zusammenarbeiten können
und da sehr häufig in so einem
plakativen Gegensätzen verhaftet sind wo
es irgendwie so entweder ist es der
Staat oder ist es der Markt
genau
verbotsverband
glaube ich naja sie dürfen auch so aber
die die die sehr Verschlagwortung von
Politiker nichts zu bedeuten Schwarz
Weiß denken dass den Herausforderungen
mit denen wir heute konfrontiert sind in
keinster Art und Weise gerechten wird
vorher
gleich ausführlich antwortet Frau
Münster
ich wollte dazu sagen also diese Gefahr
einer
d-industrialisierung damit ist ja vor
allem vor dem letzten Winter aber auch
immer noch ausgerechnet der Bunde der
Präsident des Bundesverbandes der
deutschen Industrie durch die Medien
gegangen und er hat das schon finde ich
in der Sorge der Herausforderung
Ausdruck verliehen was wir jetzt
innerhalb von ein paar Tagen also ich
hätte auch den Autosalon Shanghai fand
ich eine sehr es war eine Frisur genau
und jetzt Viessmann ausgerechnet hatten
wir schon bei der Wärmepumpe aber das
zeigt natürlich schon die Idee dass
Firmen gehen und Deutschland die drücken
zu drehen und sagen hier nicht mehr aber
gerne in den USA dass das nicht so weit
hergeholt ist und nur ein ein
lobbyistenverband waren sondern das ist
da Probleme gibt und das wäre ja
so und deswegen ist ja nur nicht so
gegen die Chinese der der Liberalen ich
habe es ja eingangs gesagt du sie haben
heute die einmalige Chance mal zu sagen
nicht du wogegen sie sind sondern wofür
sie sie sagt die ganze Zeit ich weiß ich
weiß nicht mehr aus anderen Sendung
wiederholen sie sind fürs aber wofür
sind sie noch ja also das was jetzt im
Bild dort steht nicht kommt nämlich dass
wir die industrialisiert werden deswegen
Grenze bei mir absolut offene Türen ein
bei der Sorge mit Standort viel
verschüttete mich nichts passiert in der
Vergangenheit deswegen müssen wir jetzt
einiges dafür tun damit dieser Standort
stärker wird und das ist natürlich ein
äh was machen
und ich wollte auf einen Punkt hinaus
die Frage Markt und Stadt die Sie
angesprochen haben bei der Frage der
Infrastruktur Stichwort natürliches
Monopol z.B bei der Gas Netzversorgung
sind wir absolut bei einander da hat der
Staat eine planende Aufgabe weil es ja
beispielsweise beim Gas Netz nicht sechs
verschiedene gibt sondern es gibt ein
Gast was zu mir
sie müssen mich ja Sie dürfen bleiben
also wir drücken natürlich nicht auf den
Knopf sondern ich finde es ist ein
mahnendes Beispiel dass wir keine
absurden Entscheidung treffen die
Unternehmen aus dem Land treiben und
hier gerade für ein Gefahr für den
Mittelstand werden aber bei der Frage
der Technologie oftmals und da ging es
ja auch darum was Herr li gerade sagte
ich stelle eines fest das haben sie auch
gesagt zu Recht Deutschland ist aus
verdammt vielen ausgestiegen aber zu
wenig eingestiegen und wenn ich mir
jetzt den Vergleich zu China anschaue
dann könnte könnten ihre Worte den
Eindruck erwecken dass die da ganz viele
Solarpaneele bauen und ganz viele
Elektroautos aber nicht die Realität in
China ist die bauen unfassbar viele
Kohlekraftwerke und haben jetzt glaube
ich 43
Atomkraftwerke das ist sogar ich will
das nicht kopieren ausdrücklich nicht
aber ich stelle mir die Frage was können
wir einsteigen sollten doch die Nummer
eins in Photovoltaik sollten wir neben
Markus Söder in Bayern
alle seine Klimaschutzziele in China
werden die nicht Zeit also alles klar
ergänzen weil weil sie gesagt haben also
in Deutschland diese Debatte die die FDP
geführt hat über die Laufzeit verlängern
ich glaube wir sind einer Meinung von
dem Thema
über den Winter richtig war an der
Stelle aber als ob die ganze Welt aus
der Kerntechnologie aussteigt ist nicht
wahr die USA steigen gerade in neue
Generation ein die USA kümmern sich um
Kernfusion Frankreich Großbritannien
schaffen
Fusionsgesetz was ich auch vorschlagen
übrigens in Deutschland Stichwort in
Technologien einsteigen wir sollten
Marktführer bleiben insbesondere
Kernfusion wirklich Physiker sagen ihnen
ähnlich wie bei uns macht man den
homöopathischen Mengen nein Kernfusion
mit den 30 Jahren frühestens ein Thema
wenn wir das hinkriegen ist es großartig
bis jetzt hat es noch funktioniert und
nicht mal dieser dieses Experiment da
neulich in Kalifornien wenn man da genau
drauf guckt war so dass man mehr Energie
rausgekriegt hat als man dort
reingesteckt aber die Gedanken
da steigt jetzt der Weltmarktführer an
Wärmepumpen das das nächste Big Business
das uns möglicherweise verloren geht was
machen wir sie sind die Regierung was
machen Sie also ich kann natürlich die
unternehmerischen Entscheidung von
Viessmann jetzt nur mutmaßen an der
Stelle aber meine Sorge schon auch die
Debatte und das Gebäude Energiegesetz
was ich habe mich mein vor mein Ärger
Ausdruck verliehen dass das dazu führt
dass solche Unternehmen sagen was
passiert da gerade ist deine Eruption
sozusagen weg von der Technologie die
wir sehr sehr gut beherrschen also
fließt man ist ja auch sehr erfolgreich
nebenbei gesagt auch bei neuen
Generation von Gasheizung wird das in
Deutschland quasi weggeschoben und wird
sich nur auf eine Technologie
konzentriert die wir noch nicht
ausreichend weit entwickelt haben
sie machen gerade Gesetze die dazu
führen dass doch ein Unternehmen wie
Viessmann egal ob wir demnächst zu 100
Prozent Wärmepumpen oder zu 60%
Wärmepumpen haben die haben doch in
Wahrheit goldene Zeiten vor sich und
trotzdem entscheiden die sich zu
verkaufen oder wegzugehen und
möglicherweise machen andere das
Geschäft das doch der Punkt wie stellen
wir das denn sicher dass wir diese
Wertschöpfung die wir selber in Gang
gesetzt haben dass wir die am Ende auch
selber abgreifen das doch indem wir ganz
konkret beispielsweise ein Gebäude
Energiegesetz machen wofür man noch eine
Marktchance hat ganz konkret das ist
doch der Grund warum ich das Gesetz
jetzt nicht durchwinkel also es ist
Wasser auf meine Mühen weil sie sagen
wir mussten
große Subventionen in die Hand nehmen
wir müssten große strukturell wirklich
große Investments machen wir müssen die
großen Banken des Landes die großen
Geldgeber des Landes zusammenbringen und
sagen Freunde das was die Chinesen jetzt
machen das was andere südostasiatische
Länder machen nämlich günst sich
Wärmepumpentechnologie zu entwickeln das
machen wir selbst also ich möchte dass
es die Unternehmen in Deutschland tun
auch wer mit Punkten Technologien aber
auch andere und ich glaube wir deswegen
kämpfe ich ja für ein Gebäude
Energiegesetz was vernünftig ist damit
das was bei Viessmann mutmaßlich
passiert ist oder passieren wird bei
anderen nicht passiert erstens und
zweitens der Hinweis die sie geben weil
erwecken den Eindruck da würde Geld
irgendwo herkommen zufällig und das
müsste man nur richtig lenken wir reden
wahrscheinlich
gezielt ist ein interessantes Wort aber
müssen wir schon konkret werden meint
sie Steuergeld also heißt das wir wollen
mehr Subventionen einfach nur machen in
der Hoffnung das klappt okay ich finde
die Vergangenheit die Vergangenheit
finde ich hat bewiesen dass das reine
subventionsregie die ein Großteil der
Energie wenn in Deutschland okay war
darauf aufgebaut nicht so richtig gut
funktioniert hat und ich stelle fest
dass andere Länder der Welt auch die
Vereinigten Staaten ein anderen Weg
jedenfalls gehen bei der Anwendung der
Technologie
okay einmal Frau Weber
also diese riesigen Programme die laufen
auch in den USA wie machen die das und
dann wird mich einmal von Herrn
interessieren wie haben die Chinesen
dass sie in der Vergangenheit gemacht
weil sie sagen man kann sich das dort
sie kennen das sehr gut genau angucken
wie dieser
Know-how Technologietransfer wie der
Stadt gefunden hat und wie sich
plötzliche Dinge entwickelt haben wo man
mit Staunen im Auge der Vorstand und
sich fragte wie war das eigentlich
möglich aber erst sie ja also ich denke
der Punkt das ist nicht nur um
Subventionen gehen sollte ist schon
richtig man könnte sich zum Beispiel
über so Modelle Gedanken machen wie
Enterprise Island was ein staatliches
investment-unternehmen ist das
investiert und dann aber entsprechend
auch Anteile hat und wenn man jetzt mit
der einen Hand einen garantierten Markt
für Wärmepumpen schafft und mit der
anderen Hand in einen Wärmepumpen
Unternehmen investieren würde dann würde
man relativ sicher da auch ähm
entsprechende returns drauf haben so
dass man dann eben auch nicht jetzt
einfach nur
Steuergelder irgendwie hinausbläst
sondern sie eben ausgibt und im
Gegensatz im Gegenzug dazu ein asset hat
was ein asset hat dass ein garantierten
Markt hat dass wenn man gleichzeitig
sicherstellt dass alle Menschen
Wärmepumpen kaufen müssen dann eben auch
entsprechend einen ein Return einbringen
wird und ich denke so eine Art von
Modelle sind wichtig und muss man im
Kontext von der Art von Transformation
mit dem was zu tun haben ins Spiel
bringen also muss das staatlich dann
auch wirklich
Ansagen fördern die Strukturen schaffen
und das große Geld auch bereit schöne
aber eben auch nicht nur nicht nur
fördern sondern auch sicherstellen dass
der Staat auch als return auf diese
Förderung dann auch entsprechenden
Anteil hat also wenn man sich zum
Beispiel Tesla anschaut aber am Anfang
enorm viel amerikanische Steuergeld
reingeflossen ist und dann aber
letztlich der Stadt keinen Anteil an
diesem Unternehmen hatte und man dann
hinterher eben so jemand hat wie einen
Maske der wahnsinnig reich geworden ist
dann ist glaube ich irgendwie was schief
gelaufen hat man einerseits richtig
investiert indem man gesagt hat man
investiert in so eine Technologie wie
E-Autos und hat damit eine entscheidende
Wende gebracht aber gleichzeitig eben
nicht sichergestellt dass diese
öffentlichen Investitionen dann auch
refinanziert werden damit man diese
ganzen Herausforderungen mit jemand
konfrontiert ist auch entsprechend
stemmen kann der ironische Punkt an dem
Ding ist dass wir Anteile daran hatten
daimler hat er Anteile an Tesla und hat
sie dann sehr gut verkauft war warum
auch immer
Elli zwei Beispiele genau zwei Beispiele
2010 zu Beginn meiner Korrespondenz
damals foxcon größte Auftragshersteller
von allen möglichen
iPhones Mitarbeiter pro Fabrik und so
weiter ich hatte da gab es Skandale um
schlechte Arbeitsbedingungen hohe
Selbstmordraten und so weiter ich habe
da einen 17-Jährigen Wanderarbeiter
darauf gesucht der die miserablen
Arbeitsbedingungen damals da geschildert
hat und den habe ich mit dem habe ich
Kontakt gehalten hier alle ein zwei
Jahre wieder besucht paar später
arbeitete er schon nicht mehr bei
foxkorn und schraubte da irgendwelche
iPhone zusammen sondern auf der anderen
Straßenseite Huawei auch mal billig
angefangen aber dann in der Zeit schon
ein Technologie Innovator ja das war
dann auch keine Fabrik mehr sondern
hatte schon Campus Charakter jetzt
besuche ich diesen oder habe den zuletzt
2018 gesehen und auch weiter Kontakte
halten der hatte inzwischen mit mit 20
ein kleines Startup für Medizintechnik
was ich damit sagen will es ist was wir
so damals in den Nullerjahren also
billig billig können auch die Chinesen
machen irgendwie mit Ihren billigen
Arbeitskräften und so weiter dadurch ist
auch Know-how verloren gegangen oder
exportiert worden und dieses nur wurde
weiterentwickelt und China das ist
natürlich deswegen ist es nicht
natürlich nicht nur der Staat das hat
auch was mit der Mentalität zu tun mit
dem Willen aber der Staat hat parallel
zu dem Fox convert zu dem Huawei Campus
in dieser Stadt vor den Toren
hongkongsschen inzwischen das Silicon
Valley Ostasiens hat da
Forschungseinrichtung gebaut
Universitäten Institute die sich
konzentriert haben auf Technologie jetzt
ist es ein Hightech Zentrum
so das ist das das war das das ist so
ein Beispiel wie das in China vonstatten
ging also vielleicht belasse ich das
dann erstmal
könnte man auch noch lange drüber reden
trotzdem noch mal die Frage an Sie zu
dem Themenkomplex um den noch am
abzuschließen hätte nochmal die Frage
wenn Sie das so hören wenn Sie das so
sehen und noch mal ich kenne das
kritische Verhältnis der FDP zu
Subventionen und so weiter und
Marktwirtschaft ist auch eine gute Sache
und hat ja auch an vielen Dingen sehr
vieles bewirkt aber wenn man sich das so
weltweit auch anschaut die ganz großen
Entwicklungen die wir gerade sehen die
die großen technologiesprünglich mal
auch das Silicon Valley letztendlich in
den USA kommt direkt sozusagen
amerikanischen Verteidigungssystem
heraus aus dem Pentagon heraus
finanzierte die Idee wir fahren jetzt
zum Mond war quasi der Startschuss zum
zum Silicon Valley ne das kann man
glaube ich so verkürzt einfach mal sagen
das heißt da denken Sie nicht drüber
nach in der deutschen Politik zu sagen
was was machen wir da stellen das in der
Europäischen Union keine Subvention
ausgestattet werden wenn das Vergleichen
gerade im Vergleich zu dem was Europa
macht dann sind wir gar nicht so viel
weniger unterwegs dass das eine was mich
auf dem gestanden dass in China Bild
gezeichnet wird was mir offen gesagt
schon ein bisschen zu positivistisch ist
also wir müssen aufpassen dass wir es
nicht glorifizieren im Sinne so habe ich
sie nicht verstanden dass das so
kopieren müssen denn am Ende ist es dass
es ein Unrechtsstaat ist darüber sind
wir hier einer Meinung da kannst auch
keine Meinung geben aber dass dieses
sehr planwirtschaftliche in einer
Diktatur eine gewisse Zeit erfolgreich
sein kann bei Krone haben wir schon
anders gesehen das verstehe ich durchaus
nur ähm ich tue mir schwer damit zu
sagen dass insbesondere vor dem
Hintergrund des Auslands dieser Debatte
mich der Klimaschutz da ist China nun
ein eindeutig nicht auf dem richtigen
Fahrt china macht diesen Wohlstand in
dem beispielsweise russische fossile
Ressourcen massenhaft jetzt ausgekauft
und natürlich ein Stück weit auch der
Politik des Westens damit konträr geht
also ich will damit nur deutlich machen
China er kauft sich auch vieles von dem
auf Kosten des globalen Klimas auf
Kosten der Umwelt und auf Kosten der
Menschen das muss
passen dass man nicht anfängt aber gut
wir sind jetzt in der Diskussion wir ich
wir bringen China nicht als Beispiel ein
um alles was schlecht läuft davon zu
lernen sondern was was eben gut läuft
und zusammen ja teilweise ja aber es ist
ja auch eine deswegen weil es auch eine
extreme neue Herausforderung ist für für
auch für Deutschland oder insbesondere
für Deutschland und deswegen da genau
hinzuschauen was wie und
wie der Hase von der Schlange Politik
sagen sie haben da völlig recht es
werden neue Atomkraftwerke gebaut es
werden auch neue Kohlekraftwerke aber
immerhin noch besser sind als das was
bisher bestand weil der Energiebedarf so
groß ist ja ja aufgrund des enorm
Wachstums was ja weiter vonstatten geht
aber man darf auch nicht und das müssen
wir und da sind wir dann halt wieder da
sind wir über uns wir wer wollen ja
nicht davon lernen wie die Chinesen
coole Kraftwerke bauen sondern sie sind
eben die Chinesen investieren und bauen
so viel Solar
Photovoltaikanlagen und Windkraftanlagen
quasi alle oect-staaten zusammen und das
ist natürlich darauf schauen wir und
damit schaffen die sich natürlich auch
eine Industrie die dann wiederum hier
rüberschwappt es sind ja nicht die
Kohlekraftwerke die hier nach Europa
kommen sondern es sind diese
Solarpaneelen die windtur die dann auf
von China hierher kommen und von der wir
jetzt vor einer Abhängigkeit stehen und
wenn wir sagen wir wollen diese
Energiewende wirklich auch die Zeit
drängt ja das wissen wir ja auch alle da
muss dann jetzt was passieren weil wenn
ich mir angucken wie z.B dann auch mit
der Immobilität warum die Immobilität
warum jetzt jedes vierte Auto auch ein
E-Auto ist das liegt auch daran ich habe
ihn hatte das mal auch mal geschildert
also vor meiner Strahl also in dem Haus
wo ich gewohnt habe in der Straße da kam
plötzlich ein Bautrupp von 200 Leuten
die haben die ganze Straße aufgerissen
ich fragte was machen sie da die Bauten
zeitgleich Glasfasernetz fernwärmer
Anschluss und ich also eh Ladesäule
Geschwindigkeit
ich will nicht sagen also das müssen wir
eins zu eins kopieren
oh das könnte ja eine Geschichte aber
alle schon wieder fertig und äh und die
Bauarbeiter waren schon wieder
weitergezogen was ich nur damit meine
das geschieht in einer Geschwindigkeit
die uns vor enorm Herausforderungen
stellt und wo ich manchmal inzwischen
die Befürchtung habe wir verzetteln und
zu sehr in kleinen klein und kommen den
nicht mehr hinterher das ist nicht
unbedingt dass ich das diese
Geschwindigkeit eins zu eins wirklich
von Herzen wünsche ich habe nur eher die
Befürchtung ähm wir verzetteln und zu
sehr mit unseren Diskussion und bemerken
nicht wie der technologische Fortschritt
in den anderen Teilen der Welt von
vonstatten geht also schneller
innovativer zu sein da haben wir kein
Widerspruch ich habe nur davor gewarnt
dass
wenn schon verstanden